some bringing you the latest storm that  developing story we brought you from  Poland because you remember we told you  that a senior U.S intelligence official  says that Russian missiles have crossed  the border into Poland which is a NATO  member killing two people and of course  NATO membership confers protection for  Any Nation it means that an attack on  one member of NATO is an attack on all  of them of course Ukraine is is not a  NATO member which is why uh NATO has not  come to its support militarily in terms  of boots on the ground well we are  hearing that the Polish prime minister  has ordered an emergency meeting of  their National Security Bureau this  evening and of course they'll bring you  any more developments as they come in